ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
BAUER-KAHAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON.
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE
[inaudible]
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER WICKS [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
[inaudible]
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY OSHA
RIVER.
TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE PERSIAN NEW YEAR NOW RUZ
LITERALLY MEANS NEW DAY. FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS THE PERSIAN
NEW YEARS HAS BEEN CELEBRATED
DURING THE SPRING EQUINOX
MARKING A TIME OF RENEWAL IN NEW
BEGINNINGS.
IT IS A GREAT FALL AND HOPEFUL
TIME CELEBRATING THE MIRACLE OF
NATURE.
IN CELEBRATING THE COMING OF
SPRING NUMBER CELEBRATES A
RENEWING OF THE WORLD.
UNDER GREEN LEAVES AND SHOOTS
EMERGE FROM THEIR BRANCHES IN
EMPTY FIELDS.
A NEW SEASON THE GROWTH BEGINS.
AND WITH IT THE HOPE FOR A
BOUNTIFUL YEAR.
IT IS A TIME WHEN ALL THE WORLD
SEEMS TO BE MANIFESTING THE
MIRACLE OF NEW LIFE.
THIS IS ALSO A REFLECTIVE IN
PEACEFUL TIME.
AS ENCOURAGED BY THE PERSIAN
SPIRITUAL POET RUMI WHO WROTE.
LET US RAISE THE QUALITY OF OUR
THOUGHTS IN WORDS NOT OUR VOICES.
IT IS RAIN THAT GROWS FLOWERS
NOW UNDER.
NOW MOMMY DOWNWARDS IN WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU AS HE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE MISTER CHIU.
BUT ISN'T GERMAN PLEASE JOIN US
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
IS A LITTLE [inaudible]
OUR THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH SIX
TWENTY NINETEEN HE'S ONLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON WILL ELOISE GOMEZ
REYES ASSEMBLY MEMBER FORTY
SEVEN JUST PRESIDING CHIEF
QUIRKY DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
BEING QUICK KATHLEEN AND LUIS
READING THE FOLLOWING A PLACE ON
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BURNER FOR THAT MR GIVES IT
MOVS.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IAN CALDERON AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JIM COOPER. FOR A FUNERAL --
DEATH IN THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ.
WE ARE MOVING [inaudible]
TO PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MCCARTY NAZARIAN AND
SANTIAGO. TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I FOR THE REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOLEY DOLLY
FONG AND GRAY TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
WANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RE REFER OR THE FOLLOWING BILLS.
TO COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
GRAYSON.
FROM THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY THREE B. M. P. COMMITTEE
FROM THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA
COMMITTEE.
AND THEN BACK TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE.
A WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL
BE THE ORDER
MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE A FORMER
MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE WHO IS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
HONORABLE DANTE ACOSTA.
WELCOME BACK SIR.
AND MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST RECOGNIZE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI. FOR HIS
GAS INTRODUCTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SAW IT IS ALL MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE OUR MY
KNEES.
ASTOR CAM WITHOUT HER HUSBAND
DANIEL.
AND THEIR CHILDREN ABI YELLOW
AND THE SEVER ALL UP IN THE
GALLERY.
AND THE MY AND THE SERA THEY
MAKE ME -- A
GRANDFATHER WELCOME TO THE FLOOR
THAT'S HELPED ME YEAH WELCOME
THEM
.
A PART OF A MISTER MCCARTY MISS
MCCARTY OF A GUESSTIMATE CHAMBER
TODAY.
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MATT
BARNES TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR A
MATT IS A SACRAMENTO IN A
LIFELONG SACRAMENTO IN.
THAT PRODUCT IN THE PRIDE OF DEL
CAMPO HIGH SCHOOL AS WELL AS
UCLA WENT ON TO PLAY IN THE NBA
FOR FOURTEEN YEARS.
INCLUDING AS A FINAL YEAR YOU
WERE HE WON AN NBA CHAMPIONSHIP
WITH THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
HE'S NW WORKING ON COMMUNITY IN
THE COMMUNITY ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ISSUES AND
FOCUSING ON OUR YOUTH.
HE'S HERE TODAY TO LEARN ABOUT
THE LET'S LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND ENGAGE WITH HIS LAWMAKERS I
PLEASE HELP ME IN GIVING A WARM
WELCOME. TO MATT BARNES THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER MEMBERS.
MEMBER SINCE KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL MANAGEABLE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF GUEST WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
PLEASE KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS
TO A MINIMUM MISTER PATTERSON.
YOU HAVE SPECIAL GUEST IN THE
CHECK IN DATE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OUT
MEMBERS TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME.
FRESNO STATE'S COLLEGE OF
AGRICULTURE IN THEIR AG
LEADERSHIP CLASS.
THE STAND UP TEN STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
UNIVERSITY AS EMERGING LEADERS
IN AGRICULTURE WHO HAVE A DEEP
INTEREST IN PUBLIC POLICY.
THEY ARE HERE TODAY TO EXPAND
THEIR LEADERSHIP SKILLS TO MEET
WITH THE REPRESENTATIVES TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND TO DISCUSS TOPICS.
IMPORTANT TO AGRICULTURE.
ALSO WHAT HERE WITH THESE TEN
STUDENTS SANDRA REALLY WHO IS
THE DEAN OF FRESNO STATE COLLEGE
OF AGRICULTURE MICHAEL THOMAS
THE ASSOCIATE DEAN.
OF FRESNO STATE COLLEGE OF
AGRICULTURE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME THEY ARE HERE TODAY WILL YOU
WELCOME THEM TO THE FLOOR
AND MR
SALAS.
YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH US TODAY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THAT TODAY I AM PLEASED
TO INTRODUCE GAS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION.
THEY'RE UP IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
HELP ME IN WELCOMING THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE KERN
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION --
RICHARD CHAPMAN FOR KINGS COUNTY
LANCE --
FROM SAN JOAQUIN PARTNERSHIP
MIGHT AMAZON FROM MADERA COUNTY
ECONOMIC --
BOBBY CONN AND FROM FRESNO
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION LIANE EAGER THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE IN THAT.
HELP US FUEL THE WORLD FEED THE
WORLD.
AND HELP A RATE THE STRONG
ECONOMIC BACKBONE WHICH IS HERE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS WELCOME THEM
TO THE TO THE FOR PLEASE
.
AND MISTER SANTIAGO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE YOU FROM
MY DESK.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO PRESENT
SOMEBODY VERY IMPORTANT --
THE LOS ANGELES CITY AND THAT'S
NO OTHER THAN CAROL SITES
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE QUEEN OF
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES BY MANY OF
US.
NOW MANY OF US KNOW HER.
BECAUSE OF HER CHARM HER GREAT
IN HER ABILITY TO GET THINGS
DONE.
BUT IN DOWNTOWN WE ALSO KNOW HER
FOR LEADING THE CHARGE OF THE
WHAT WE CALL THE DOWNTOWN
RENAISSANCE.
HELPING TO BRING CLOSE TO THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT
AND THIRTY THREE THOUSAND UNITS
OF HOUSING JUST IN ONE SMALL
REGION.
IT'S WITH GLEE GREAT PLEASURE
THAT I PRESENT --
TODAY CAROL SHOTS THE FORMER C.
E. O. ON TIME LOS ANGELES BID
AND TODAY WE HAVE A RESOLUTION
OF PRESENT WITH HER TO HER.
AND IF ANY MEMBER LIKES TO TAKE
A PICTURE WITH THEIR WE WELCOME
YOU TO THE BACK [inaudible]
MEMBERS
.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH.
YOU HAVE GUESTS THAT HAVE JOINED
US IN THE GALLERY MEMBERS PLEASE
GIVE ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
TODAY IS MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME
IN THE GALLERY AT AND RECOGNIZE
MEMBERS AND ASSOCIATES OF THE
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ABOVE ME AND TO MY LEFT.
AMONG THEM ARE BUSINESS OWNERS
UTILITIES EXECUTIVES COLLEGE OF
THE CANYONS OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATION
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF THE ARTS
ADMINISTRATORS AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ACROSS
SANTA CLARITA.
I APPRECIATE MY MEMBER
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US THIS
MORNING FOR A MEETING ABOUT
EVENTS.
AND HAPPENINGS IMPORTANT TO THIS
GROUP AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THEIR CONTINUED WORK WITH OUR
LOCAL CAN START SONGS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND AT THE
ADMINISTRATION TO TALK ABOUT
CURRENT.
POLICIES BUDGET AND ISSUES THAT
AFFECT OUR RATE REGION AND THE
STATE.
I AM HAPPY TO SEE SO MANY OF MY
FRIENDS AND CONSTITUENTS HERE IN
THE CAPITAL PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE THAT IS A C. R. TO BY MR
NECESSARY IN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO BUY ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
PERSIAN NEW YEAR.
MR IS ARIAN YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S MY
HONOR TO PRESENT A C. R. TO AN
API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
RESOLUTION TO COMMEMORATE MARCH
TWENTIETH. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AS THE BEGINNING OF NOTICE THE
PERSIAN NEW YEAR.
NO DOES IS A COMBINATION OF TWO
FOUR STE WORD NO MEANS NEW AND
THE SECOND WORD RUSE MEANS DAY.
TOGETHER THE WORD MEANS NEW DAY
WHICH IS THE NAME GIVEN TO THE
NEW YEAR IN THE PERSIAN CALENDAR.
NO DO CELEBRATES THE RENEWAL
SPRING USHERS IN ALONG WITH THE
UNIVERSAL MESSAGES OF
BROTHERHOOD FRIENDSHIP AND CO
EXISTENCE FOR ALL OF HUMANITY.
THE DAY'S FOCUS ON
RECONCILIATION AND
NEIGHBORLINESS CONTRIBUTE TO
CULTURAL DIVERSITY AND
COOPERATION AMONG PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND
BACKGROUNDS.
COMMEMORATING NOTICE ALLOWS US
TO BREAK DOWN SOME OF THE WALLS
OTHERS WOULD TRY TO PUT IN PLACE
BY REVEALING.
OUR COMMON HUMANITY.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THE FIRST ROLE. TO BE OPENED FOR
CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER IS THERE.
THANK YOU MISSION IS ERIN.
AND ISRAEL S..
PLEASE HOLD YOUR APPLAUSE DURING
DEBATE.
THREE OF US.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND
THE LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF ACR --
TO NO RUSES A REMINDER THAT EVEN
OUT OF THE DARKEST DAYS THERE IS
LIGHT.
AT ITS CORE IT'S A CELEBRATION
OF RENEWAL THE MESSAGE OF PEACE
MUTUAL RESPECT AND SOLIDARITY.
BETWEEN GENERATIONS AND
COMMUNITIES HAS NEVER BEEN
TIMELIER.
TODAY WE MARK THE NEW BEGINNING
OFFERED BY NO RUSE AND WISH
EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND ALL THOSE
WHO CELEBRATE ACROSS THE NATION
AND AROUND THE WORLD.
A PROSPEROUS AND SWEET NEW YEAR
LOVE JOY AND PEACE I URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON A C. R..
TO THANK YOU MS RIVER S. MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I RISE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ACR TO WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE CELEBRATION OF
NOWRUZ.
AS THE AUTHOR STATED NUMBERS CAN
BE TRANSLATED TO MEAN NEW DAY.
IN ORDER TO SIGNIFY A SENSE OF
RENEWAL AND RESTORATION.
NO ROSA CELEBRATED BY THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE AND REPRESENTS THE
MANY DIVERSE ETHNIC COMMUNITIES
AND RELIGIOUS BACKGROUNDS IN
CALIFORNIA.
NO RUZ GIVES EVERYONE REGARDLESS
OF ETHNIC CULTURAL RELIGIOUS OR
ECONOMIC BACKGROUND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH HOPE FOR A
PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR.
FILLED WITH SUCCESS BEAUTY
FRIENDSHIP ENJOY.
AS WE ENTER ANOTHER LEGISLATIVE
SESSION.
WITH THE GLORIOUS THIS OF THE
SUPER BLOOM AND I AM NOT
REFERRING TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE WEST SIDE.
WE ARE PRESENTED WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RENEW OUR SENSE
OF HOPE IN THE PROMISE OF THIS
GREAT STATE. TO VOTE AND PASSED
POLICIES THAT RESTORE EQUITY
ATTACK BIAS BIAS AGAINST PEOPLE
AGAINST REGION'S AND AGAINST
HISTORICAL PRACTICES AND THAT
SUPPORT AND INNOVATIVE AND JUST
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY FOR BRINGING ACR TO THE
FLOOR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS KAMLAGER-DOVE MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF ACR TO I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE FOUR OH
FIVE FOR BRING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION.
FOLKS WHO AREN'T FAMILIAR WITH
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY OFTEN MISS
THAT OUR CREDIT OUR COMMUNITY IS
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE.
CALIFORNIA'S JEWISH COMMUNITY
INCLUDES MANY SO RAFI JEWS WHO
ARE.
PROUD TO TRACE THEIR ROOTS BACK
TO THE MIDDLE EAST AND NORTH
AFRICA.
IN THIS INCLUDES A LARGE AND
VIBRANT PERSON JEWISH COMMUNITY
THAT CELEBRATES ENORMOUS.
THANKS TO ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THIRTY YEARS AFTER THE PERSIAN
JEWISH COMMUNITY IS BECOMING
MORE SPECIFICALLY AND
POLITICALLY ENGAGED.
AND BRINGING THEIR UNIQUE
HISTORY AND PERSPECTIVE INTO OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
I'M PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT A
LARGE AND VIBRANT PERSIAN
COMMUNITY OF ALL FAITHS AND
BACKGROUNDS IN THE WEST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY.
AND PLEASE TO JOIN WITH THEM IN
CELEBRATING A ROOSTS AND THE
BEGINNING OF SPRING AND THE
REBIRTH OF NATURE.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IN BY SO MANY OF THE
SPEAKERS HERE IN THE AUTHOR.
NO ROOTS MEANS NEW DAY IN FARSI.
AND IN THE SPIRIT OF NO REUSS WE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO EMBRACE
CHANGE IN OUR LIVES AND TO RENEW
OUR FOCUS ON THE WORK OF SERVING
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND A FLIP UP LIFTING THOSE IN
OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE IN NEED.
IN THAT SPIRIT I WISH TO I WISH
TO EVERYONE HERE AND EVERYONE
WHO CELEBRATES NOR REUSS MUBARAK
AND A RUSE PIRO'S I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL DR CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SPEAKER I OR
SO RISE IN SUPPORT OF WHAT ACR --
TO IN CELEBRATING.
THE NO RULE WITH THE US KALLONI
IS THE HOME OF THE MANY MANY.
PERISH AND A COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
AND THE WE CELEBRATE THE
PARTICULARLY IN THE CITY OF
IRVINE --
ABOUT THE A POOR FIRST A WHILE --
NEAR -- TO
ADAPT A THOUSAND SYMBOL PEOPLE
GATHER AS SO SABRINA --
OUTING IN CELEBRATION OF THE ON
THE RULES.
AND THAT THIS IS SAW A
DEMONSTRATION OF ALL ALL
DIFFERENT DIVERSE THE DIVERS SO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS SAW IN OUR
DISTRICT AND CITY OVER IRVINE --
WE IS TO GATHER TO CELEBRATE
THAT DIFFERENT CULTURES SORRY
AND WE LOAN AND TO SUPPORT THIS
YACHT.
TO THANK YOU TAX CHOI.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
MR IS AIRING YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I THINK --
THE BEST CLOSE IS --
THE THE WORDS --
CITED BY REVEREND OSHITA AND SHE
GAVE THE PRAYER --
SO I WILL LEAVE IT WITH HER
RIGHT CITING --
ROOMIES WORDS --
AND I WILL JUST SAY I THINK YOU.
KNOW LOSE THEM OF IRAQ AND WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE ALL OF YOU JOIN ME
IN SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU.
AND MR HYSTERIA AND YOU LIKE THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON A C. R.
.
TO THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY THREE
CO AUTHORS ADDED TO THE
RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER NECESSARY
AND I WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
YOU FROM MY DESK IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR SPECIAL
GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER SPEAKER
OF WANTED TO FIRST AND FOREMOST
SAY THAT --
THERE WERE HIGH SINCE --
DROPPED OFF AT ALL OF OUR
OFFICES SO PLEASE ENJOY THAT AS
A CELEBRATION OF THE OF OF
SPRING AND NOTICE --
AND TODAY WE'RE JOINED --
BY IRANIAN AMERICAN DELEGATION
COMPOSED OF PROFESSIONALS
COMMUNITY LEADERS AND HARDEST TO
WITNESS OUR SIX NOTICE --
RECOGNITION BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY I WITH ME TODAY
OUR DR AMIR HOW MEETING AND
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT IN GLOBAL TERRORISM AND
FORMER U. S. SPECIAL AGENT IN
CHARGE.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DRAGONFORCE A LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER MAGGIE SINGLE
HANDEDLY ARRANGED A BEAUTIFUL
HAVE SEEN.
A TABLE ON DISPLAY AT THE NOTICE
RECEPTION EARLIER TODAY IN ROOM.
THREE SEVENTEEN DOCTOR NIGHT
HE'D HAVE SHERRY.
PRESIDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO ZERO
ASTRI IN ASSOCIATION AND A
COMMUNITY LEADER MISTER MOHAMMED
GOAL SHINY OWNER OF BAGHDAD
RADIO.
A CULTURAL OF A CULTURAL PERSIAN
RADIO STATION FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SACRAMENTO'S VERY OWN
SHEREEN REGINE ANCHOR AND
REPORTER FOR CBS --
THIRTEEN THERE ARE MANY MORE
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS THAT WE
HAVE SITTING IN THE BACK AS WELL
AS RIGHT ABOVE US.
THAT HAVE JOINED FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND NO RESULTS SHOW
MOM ABOUT ACT
[inaudible]
OKAY MEMBERS.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN ORDER.
WE HAVE A NUMBER REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE THIRD READING FILE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
IT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO ACR FORTY FIVE LOCAL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE BY SONY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
CELEBRATING WOMEN IN PUBLIC
OFFICE DAY.
MS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
FORTY FIVE A LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS RESOLUTION WHICH
PROCLAIMS MARCH NINETEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN AS WOMEN IN PUBLIC
OFFICE DAY.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS WHEN IT
COMES TO GETTING WOMEN ELECTED
TO OFFICE.
CURRENTLY THREE OUT OF OUR EIGHT
STATEWIDE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS ARE WOMEN. FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
WE HAVE A FEMALE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALSO HAS
TWO FEMALE US SENATORS
REPRESENTING US IN DC.
AS WELL AS A FEMALE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE OF FROM CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE ELECTED THE FIRST FEMALE
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
[inaudible]
AND FINALLY.
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY
TWO SISTERS ARE SERVING TOGETHER
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
GEE I WONDER SORRY DESPITE THIS
PROGRESS WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO.
CURRENTLY ONLY THIRTY SIX OUT OF
THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LEGISLATORS IN SACRAMENTO --
WOMEN.
WOMEN SEEKING PUBLIC OFFICE
OFTEN FIT PHASE EXTENSIVE
BARRIERS SUCH AS ACCESS TO
POLITICAL RESOURCES AND ACCESS
TO CHILD CARE.
A SAFE AS A SINGLE MOTHER I KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO BE BOTH.
A MOTHER AND AN EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATOR.
THAT IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
WOMEN IN PUBLIC OFFICE TO
SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER.
AGAIN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ON THIS MEASURE AND I WOULD LIKE
TO REQUEST THE FIRST ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR A CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO.
DO YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISH TO
SPEAK ON THE RESOLUTION.
SEEING NONE.
IS RUBIO SASSY THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON A C. R..
FORTY FIVE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL.
CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SEVENTY
THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
HI OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AJ ARE FIVE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND OTHERS RELATIVE THE FIREARM
SAFETY.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION AJ ARE FIVE URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO USE
CALIFORNIA AS A MODEL FOR
REASONABLE FIRE ARM SAFETY AS WE
WORK TO PASS.
NATION WHY FIREARM SAFETY
REGULATION IN COMPARISON TO THE
REST OF THE NATION CALIFORNIA
RANKED THIRD IN GUN HOMICIDES
AND SIXTEENTH AND GUN DEATHS IN
THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES.
BUT BY TWENTY SIXTEEN APPROVED
TO TWENTY FIFTH IN GUN HOMICIDES
PER CAPITA WITH THE EIGHTH LAW
LOWEST RATE OF GUN RELATED
DEATHS NATIONWIDE.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE AN EFFORT TO
IMPROVE HIS GUN VIOLENCE
STATISTICS TO COMMONSENSE
FIREARMS.
AS MENTIONED IN THE AG ARE IF
pCRIME IN CALIFORNIA THAT PERSON
IS FORBIDDEN FROM PURCHASING OR
POSSESSING FIREARMS.
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
TO ENACT A GUN PROTECTION ORDER
IN MOST STATES.
AND NINETEEN NINETIES CALIFORNIA
BAND MULTI BURST TRIGGER
ACTIVATORS AND LAST AND LAST
SESSION UPDATED AT BAND TO MAKE
IT CLEAR BUMP STOCKS IS ONE AND
THE SAME AS A MULTI BURST
TRIGGER ACTIVATOR.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE IT A
PRIORITY UNDERSTAND A ROOT CAUSE
OF GUN VIOLENCE BY CREATING A
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS.
LASTLY CALIFORNIA ENSURES BYRAM
USERS ARE PROTECTED FROM UNSAFE
FIREARMS BY PROHIBITING THE
MANUFACTURING AND IMPORTATION OF
UNSAFE HAND GUNS INTO THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S PROVEN STRONGER
FIREARM SAFETY LAWS CAN LEAD TO
A REDUCED RATE OF GUN VIOLENCE
WHICH INSURES PUBLIC SAFETY
WHILE SOME MIGHT ARGUE JUST
RESOLUTION IS NOT LEAD NEEDED
LET ME POINT.
THEM TO AN FBI STUDY THAT FOUND
75% OF FIREARMS USED IN A MASS
SHOOTING WERE PURCHASED LEGALLY
THIS IS WHY AJ ARE FIVE IS
NEEDED.
TO LET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NO
IT IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE PUBLIC THAT THIS NATION
ADDRESSES HIS GUN VIOLENCE BY
CREATING UNIVERSE OR FIREARM
SAFETY STANDARDS THEY'RE STRONG
AND REASONABLE.
CONTINUE JUST TO SUBJECT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING CAUSED BY GUN VIOLENCE
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE WHEN WE HAVE
A PROVEN WAY OF REDUCING GUN
VIOLENCE.
GUN VIOLENCE IS THE DISEASE THAT
IS DESTROYING THE LIVES OF
INNOCENT VICTIMS AND IT'S TIME
WE GET SERIOUS ABOUT ADDRESSING
THIS DISEASE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED --
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
YOU KNOW THOUGH I UNDERSTAND
WHERE MY COLLEAGUE IS COMING
FROM -- WITH
THIS RESOLUTION AND CERTAINLY I
THINK EVERYBODY IN THIS BODY.
WANTS TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE --
GUN VIOLENCE IN ACTS THAT HAVE
BEEN COMMITTED AND IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FRANKLY --
IN CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK
THERE'S THOSE OF US IN THIS BY
THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY.
DISAGREE THAT SOME OF THE LAWS
THAT WE PASSED OF ACTUALLY.
DONE THAT HAVE ACTUALLY
PREVENTED HAPPENING BECAUSE THE
REALITY IS.
AS MUCH AS WE PASSED MANY GUN
LAWS OVER THE YEARS --
MOSTLY PROHIBITING LAW ABIDING
PEOPLE FROM OWNING.
FIREARMS THAT THEY ARE
CONSTITUTIONALLY ABLE TO HAVE --
WE STILL HAVE MASS SHOOTINGS
LIKE THE ONE THAT HAPPENED IN MY
DISTRICT --
AND TO HIM A COUNTY.
LIKE THOUSAND OAKS THAT HAPPENED --
JUST HERE RECENTLY LIKE SAN
BERNADINO.
WHERE ARE NONE THE LESS?
SOME FOLKS WHO PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T OF HAD THOSE WEAPONS
STILL SON FOUND A WAY TO GET A
HOLD OF THEM AND CARRY OUT.
SOME VERY TRAGIC ATTACKS AGAINST
OUR PEOPLE AND IN MY CASE IN MY
COMMUNITY.
WE HAD A GENTLEMAN WHO HAD A
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST HIM.
HAD ACTUALLY TURNED OVER A
HANDGUN TO THE LOCAL SHERIFF
[inaudible]
AND YET.
SOMEHOW STILL MANAGE TO GET A
WEAPON.
STILL MANAGED TO OBTAIN IT.
AND USE IT AGAINST PEOPLE ONE
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE NOT ADDRESS
AND WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT BUT
THERE'S BEEN NO REAL ACTION.
MOSTLY FROM.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
OUR CURRENT ONE AND OUR PREVIOUS
ONE IS ENFORCING THE APPS
PROGRAM AND ENSURING THAT THOSE
WHO ARE PROHIBITED PERSONS
PEOPLE WITH FELONIES.
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DOCUMENT A MATH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
GETTING THOSE GUNS OUT OF THEIR
HANDS.
WE STILL HAVE.
LAST YEAR WE HAD TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE ON THAT LIST WHO HAD NOT
BEEN VISITED.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
APPS PROGRAM NOW IT'S OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
LET THAT FACT SINK IN FOR YOU.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PASSING MORE LAWS
GOING AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS.
AND RESTRICTING THEIR ABILITY TO
OWN FIREARMS.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING NOT THOSE.
WHO ARE MOST LIKELY TO CARRY OUT
THESE TYPES OF ATTACKS?
AND ENSURING THAT THAT HAPPENS.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO ON THAT FRONT.
IN MY OPINION.
AND SO I DON'T THINK THAT SAYING
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
HEY YOU SHOULD PASS ALL THESE
LAWS THAT WE PASS WHICH HAVEN'T
PREVENTED.
GUN DEATHS IN OUR STATE APPROACH
AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD ASK FOR
A NO VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION TO SPEAK ON THE
RESOLUTION.
MISTER JONES ARE YOU MAY CLOSE
IF YOU WISH THANK YOU --
YOU KNOW.
THE THE RESOLUTION REALLY.
TALKS ABOUT HAVING TO FUND IT
THE FUNDAMENTAL DUTY OF EVERY
ELECTED OFFICIAL ESPECIALLY IN
WASHINGTON DC TO HAVE THIS
DEBATE.
WHAT'S SO GREAT ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY IS WE CAN
DEBATE THESE ISSUES ON THIS
FLOOR.
AND HAVE AN ACTION TAKEN AFTER
THAT.
NOT ALL OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE
PASSED THROUGH THIS HOUSE OF
GOING TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK FOR
EXAMPLE HAVE BEEN.
HAVE BEEN VOTED NIGH SO MAY HAVE
BEEN VETO.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DO HAVE WHEN
YOU HAVE A OF A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS ISSUE
WHICH I WOULD SUBMIT.
IS A REAL PROBLEM NOT ONLY IN
THIS NATION.
BUT AS WE OPEN DESERVED IN OTHER
NATIONS BECOMING A GROWING AND
GROWING PROBLEM.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING IN
ACTION IS NOT THE SOLUTION.
THE SOLUTION IS EVERYONE COMING
TOGETHER AND COMING TO WHAT
IDEAS.
AND STRATEGIES TO CURB THIS
PERSON AND PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
ON OUR COMMUNITIES AND WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS JONES SAWYER WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE FIRST
ROW YES I WOULD.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON AJ ARE FIVE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
SAYS FOR CO AUTHORS ADDING ON TO
THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE FORTY EIGHT
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS IS AN
H. A R. THEREFORE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER SARAH VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL AND TELL YOU THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FIFTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND MR GABRIEL.
I HAVE MR GABRIEL FOR A GUEST
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THE
RESOLUTION MR GABRIEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER --
IN CONJUNCTION WITH A RESOLUTION
I RISE TODAY TO INTRODUCE
MEMBERS OF MOMS DEMAND ACTION
WHO ARE JOINING US IN THE
GALLERY.
THESE ACTIVISTS ARE PART OF THE
NATION'S LARGEST GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION ORGANIZATION EVERY
TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY WHICH HAS
MORE THAN FIVE MILLION
SUPPORTERS INCLUDING MANY IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
MOMS IN A FEW DADS AND STUDENTS
FROM ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE HERE
IN THE CAPITAL TODAY.
AND WILL BE VISITING OUR OFFICES
WITH A MESSAGE ABOUT HOW WE CAN
HELP AND OUR NATION'S GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC.
I'M SURE MANY OF YOU WILL AGREE
THAT NOTHING IS MORE POWERFUL
THAN A MOM ON A MISSION AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MOMS DEMAND
ACTION TO THE STATE CAPITOL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
.
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
FILE ITEMS FOR FIVE AND SIX AND
SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT THAT IS A C. R. FOR BY
MISTER FRAZIER.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOMETHING CURRENT RESOLUTION FOR
BY FAMILY MEMBER FRAZIER
RELATIVE TO THE CHP OFFICER KIRK
CHRIS MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
CHP OFFICER KIRK ANTHONY GRIS.
AND WATCH HAPPENED SUNDAY
SUDDENLY.
TRAGICALLY WHERE HE WAS FORMING.
BEFORE HIS DUTY THIS PAST AUGUST.
THE PAIN AND GRIEF IS FAMILY
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES HAVE
SUFFERED IS IMMEASURABLE.
AND IT DURING.
OFFICER CHRIS WAS A VETERAN CHP
OFFICER.
WHO DEVOTED EVERY DAY HE SPENT
ON THE JOB TO MAKING THE
HIGHWAYS OF THE SLAUGHTER REGION
SAFER TO TRAVEL?
HE WAS A VETERAN MOTORCYCLE
OFFICER WHO IS RESPECTED.
AND BE LOVED BY HIS COLLEAGUES.
THE US MARINE CORPS VETERAN.
SERVING FOUR YEARS WITH
DISTINCTION.
OFFICER CHRIS WAS DEVOTED TO HIS
DAUGHTERS KATIE AND CASEY AND
SON COLE.
COACHING THEIR SPORTS TEAMS
OFTEN.
HE WAS LIVING IN HE WAS LOVING
AND DEVOTED HUSBAND TO CARRY HIS
WIFE OF TWENTY SIX YEARS.
WHO IS ON THE FLOOR WITH US
TODAY?
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
ALSO ON THE FLOOR OF THE CITY OR
HIGHWAY PATROL COMMISSIONER
WARNED STANLEY.
AND SEVERAL OF OFFICER GRISES
COLLEAGUES OF WHO MEET CERTAIN
SOLANO DIVISION AND GOLDEN GATE
DIVISION. TO HIS COLLEAGUES
OFFICER CHRIS WAS EFFECTUALLY
KNOWN AS HOLLYWOOD.
HE GOT THE NICKNAME BECAUSE HE
COULD WEAR A MOTORCYCLE HELMET
ALL DAY LONG.
AND SOMEHOW HIS HER WOULD BE
PERFECT.
WHEN HE TOOK IT OFF?
HIS HIS DAPPER LOOKS AND BIG
HEART.
ENDEARED HIM TO EVERYONE WHO
WORKED AT THE C. H. B. SOLANO
DIVISION AND THE PUBLIC.
A COLLIE SAID OF HIM YOU HAVE
THAT OFFICERS JUST SO POSITIVE
WHO ALWAYS HAS SOMETHING TO
BRING UP BRING YOU UP AND CHEER
[inaudible]
YOU UP.
WHEN YOU SEE HIM?
KIRK ANTHONY GRIS ENROLLED IN
THE C. H. P. ACADEMY IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AFTER HIS
SERVICE IN THE MARINES.
HE STARTED IS NINETEEN YOUR CHP
CAREER IN THE OAKLAND AREA.
HE WAS ASSIGNED TO THE SOLANO
DIVISION THREE YEARS LATER
SERVING SIXTEEN YEARS THERE.
A FELLOW MOTORCYCLE OFFICER
RECALLED KIRK HAD A LOVE FOR
SERVICE.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES.
OUR DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO OFFICER
CHRIS IS ONE THAT CAN NEVER.
EVER BE REPAID.
BUT WE CAN DO ONE SMALL THING TO
HELP KEEP OFFICER GRISES.
BOB OFFICER GRIST.
IN OUR HEARTS AND MINDS.
THE RESOLUTION WE ARE VOTING ON
TODAY ACR.
FOR WILL NAME THE FIVE OH FIVE
FREEWAY FROM THE INTERSTATE
EIGHTY INTERCHANGE DIVA OF
THE CHP OFFICER KIRK CHRIS
[inaudible]
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
THIS WAS THE CHOICE OF OFFICER
CHRIS [inaudible]
HIS FAMILY.
IS LOCATED IN THE HEART OF
VACUUM BILL THE BACK OF A
COMMUNITY.
ROUGH PROGRESS IN HIS SERVICE
WILL ALWAYS [inaudible]
HE REMEMBERED.
IN CONFORMANCE WITH STATE LAW.
AFTER CALTRANS IS DETERMINE THE
COST OF CREATING A WRECKING THE
HIGHWAY SIGNS.
THEY WILL BE PAID FOR WITH
PRIVATE [inaudible]
DONATIONS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE WERE NEVER PROMISED TOMORROW
IN THIS FAMILY HAS LOST A LOVED
ONE PROTECTING US.
PLEASE DO ME THE HONOR.
OF CELEBRATING THIS FAMILY TODAY
WITH AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER MR
LACKEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GALLON BEING BEGIN BY THANKING
THE GOOD MEMBER FROM NOT
DISCOVERY BAY. FOR BRINGING THIS
OF WHERE THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF IT
TO THE FLOOR TODAY.
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
A C. R. A C. R.. FOR FOR THE
ATTENTION OF BRINGS TO THE VERY
REAL DANGER.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS FACE EVERY DAY.
IT IS WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT WE
REMEMBER THE MEN AND WOMEN.
THAT LAY DOWN THEIR LIVES. FOR
THE SAFETY OF OUR OWN.
I SHOULD ADD.
THAT I WORKED WITH EIGHT
DIFFERENT CALLINGS LOST THEIR
LIVES.
DO THE WORK.
THAT THE HIGHWAY PATROL.
DOES OFTEN COMES UNDER FIRE.
THE REALITY IS IN TIMES OF
CRISIS AND UNCERTAINTY
[inaudible]
AND DANGER.
CALIFORNIA TURNS. TO THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICERS OF OUR STATE AS BEACONS
OF HOPE AND SAFETY.
REGARDLESS OF RACE GENDER.
OR IDEOLOGY OFFICERS OF THE CHP
ARE HELD TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS.
IN WORK.
AND IN LIFE.
AND ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY THE
BROTHERHOOD CREATED.
THROUGHOUT THE AGENCY.
THE COURT OF HONOR RESOUNDS THE
FOLLOWING.
I WILL ENFORCE THE LAW WITHOUT
FEAR FAVOR OR DISCRIMINATION.
I WILL ASSIST THOSE IN PERIL OR
DISTRESS.
AND IF NECESSARY.
LAY DOWN MY LIFE.
RATHER THAN CHORE FROM THE PATH
OF DUTY.
OUR SERVICE NEVER ONCE DEVIATED
FROM THE PATH OF DUTY.
AND THEN AS MEMORY AND THE
MEMORY OF COUNTLESS OTHER
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL LOST
THEIR LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY MISTER
JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY AS CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM PALMDALE
AND FROM SOLANO COUNTY. TO
JOURNEY MEMORY OF OFFICER KIRK
ANTHONY GRIS.
WHEN OUR PEACE OFFICERS A SWORN
IN THEY TAKE AN OATH TO PUT
THEIR LIVES AT RISK ON A DAILY
BASIS?
EACH OFFICER BRAVELY DOES THIS
FOR THE PROTECTION.
AND SAFETY OF OTHERS.
THAT IS WHY IT IS SO TRAGIC TO
SEE ONE OF OUR OFFICERS LOSE
THEIR LIFE DURING WHAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP.
OFFICER GRIS WAS DESCRIBED BY
HIS COLLEAGUES AS A CARING SOUL
COMMITTED TO HELPING EVERYONE
AROUND HIM.
I HOPE WE TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
REFLECT ON THE RISKS FACED BY
OUR PEACE OFFICERS.
HONOR THE MEMORY OF OFFICER GRIS.
AND THANK HIM FOR HIS SERVICE.
AND MOST IMPORTANT.
HIS FAMILY FOR THEIR SACRIFICE
BY VOTING IN FAVOUR CREATING THE
CHP OFFICER KIRK REST MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT ON AC ARE.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE FIRST ROLL THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON A C. R. FOR THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CO AUTHORS ON A C. R..
FOR THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
THERE ARE SEVENTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ADDED TO THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS IS A FISCAL ITEM WE
WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THIS AC ARE CARPOOL OVER THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER DESIRABLE
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MR FRAZIER
I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE YOU FROM
MY DESK IN THE REAR OF THE FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I HAD THE HONOR --
WEEK AGO LAST FRIDAY TO ATTEND
THE CHP GRADUATION.
WITH OUR BELOVED GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM.
AND I SAW HIM HAND OUT. SIXTY
THREE BADGES TO NEW.
NEW HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICERS.
THE FIRST GOVERNOR TO ATTEND.
THAT HAD ME IN TEN YEARS.
AND I SEE A NEW SYNERGY GOING
ALONG WE'RE SUPPORTING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THIS WAS A CRIME. TO LOSE THIS
OFFICER ON SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN.
IF WE HAD STRONGER DETERRENTS.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO INTRODUCE
[inaudible]
KIRK'S WIFE [inaudible]
CHRIS --
DIFFERENCES IN MOVIE WHO ALSO
LOST HER HUSBAND IN THE LINE OF
DUTY.
COMMISSIONER WARNED STANLEY AND
OFFICERS FROM THE GOLDEN GATE
DIVISION AND ALSO SOLANO.
AND ADMIN STAFF OVER.
ON THE SIDE THERE FROM C. H. P.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
REMEMBER KIRK.
REMEMBER HIS SACRIFICE AND HIS
FAMILY SACRIFICE.
WHEN WE HAVE SOMETHING TO VOTE
ON?
THAT WILL PROTECT THESE OFFICERS
LIVES.
WITH THAT I INTRODUCED OUR GUESS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN PASS AND
RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
ELEVEN H. R..
TWENTY BY DOCTOR EGGMAN.
HOUSE RESOLUTION TWENTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER EIGHT MEN AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DAY.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY IT IS MY HONOR TO RISE TO
PRESENT HR TWENTY WHICH HONORS
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL DAY.
AS A DAY OF CELEBRATING AND
COMMEMORATING.
IT IS VITAL ROLE IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S NOURISH.
THE THEME THIS YEAR IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IS THE CENTENNIAL
CELEBRATION A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
TODAY IS WHEN.
THEY THAT CREATED THE FARM
BUREAU THE CDFA THE AGRICULTURE
BUT PRESIDENT'S COUNCIL AND I
LIKE TO THINK IT DID CORRESPONDS
WITH THE THE FIRST YEARS WOMEN
WERE ALLOWED TO VOTE IN SERVE IN
THIS OFFICE THAT WE START
GETTING ORGANIZED ABOUT THINGS.
YOU CAN FIND AGRICULTURIST
AROUND THE STATE AND ON
WEDNESDAY THEY'LL BE HERE ON THE
WEST STEPS --
SHOWING YOU ALL THE WHERE'S ALL
THE INNOVATIVE WAYS AND ALL THE
WAYS THAT AGRICULTURE IS
ADAPTING.
AS WE CONTINUE TO CHANGE WE
REMAIN THE LARGEST AGRICULTURE
STATE IN THE NATION.
THE VALUE LAST YEAR WAS OVER.
FOR THERE ARE MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND FARMS AND RANCHES
IN CALIFORNIA PRODUCING OVER
FOUR HUNDRED COMMODITIES.
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
ORGANIC FORMS AND PRODUCTION
CONTAINING 90% OF ORGANIC FORMS
AND 39% ORGANIC PRODUCTION.
SO I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING AGRICULTURE DAY ON
WEDNESDAY TO GO OUT AND I
FURTHER ASK AS WE THINK ABOUT
THE KEEPING OURSELVES HEALTHY
AND KEEPING OURSELVES OUR STATE
HEALTHY.
THAT WHEN YOU GO SHOPPING YOU
LOOK WHERE IT SAYS CALIFORNIA
GROWN AND LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
WE PUT OUR OUR OUR MONEY WHERE
OUR VALUES LIE AS AS WE CONTINUE.
TO TRY TO CLEAN THINGS UP WE
WANT TO RESPECT THE FARMERS ARE
OUT THERE DOING THEIR VERY BEST
IN THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
CREATE.
AND THAT WE CAN DO OUR PART BY
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYTHING IN
OUR CARDS ARE CALIFORNIA GROWN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ASK FOR THE FIRST ROLE
TO BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
MISS WALDRON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF HR.
TWENTY MY DISTRICT IS MOSTLY
AGRICULTURAL DOWN IN SAN DIEGO
MORE THAN FIVE THOUSAND FARMERS
CALL SAN DIEGO HOME.
AND MAKE THEIR LIVING ON TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES SAN
DIEGO COUNTY IN FACT HAS MORE
FAMILY FARMS.
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN THE
NATION.
THERE ARE MANY LESS THAN TEN
ACRES BUT THEY'RE STILL FARMS
THAT ARE.
WORKING --
BUSINESSES NINETEEN LARGEST FARM
ECONOMY AMONG MORE THAN THREE
THOUSAND COUNTIES NATIONWIDE AND
OUR FARM CELL NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY.
CUT FLOWERS ORNAMENTAL PLANTS
BRIGHTEN HOMES YARDS IN STORES
AVOCADOS TOMATOES CITRUS
AVOCADOS.
GRAPES AND DOZENS OF OTHER CROPS
THRIVE IN THE REGION'S
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE.
CREATING BEAUTIFUL CROP SCAPES
AB CITIZENS INCLUDE ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION TOTAL VALUE OF
PRODUCTION.
SO AGRICULTURE THRIVES FROM THE
TOP OF THE STATE TO THE BOTTOM.
AND IT'S THE ONE OF THE MAJOR
BOOSTERS OF OUR ECONOMY
STATEWIDE SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISS
MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF HR
[inaudible]
TWENTY YOU KNOW.
I WAS TALKING WITH THE MAG
STUDENTS IN THE SACK LEADERSHIP
CLASS AND ASKED ME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT'S YOUR
FAVORITE PART ABOUT BEING VICE
CHAIRMAN OF AT AND WHAT'S YOUR
FAVORITE PART ABOUT AG AND I
TOLD HIM YOU GUYS IT'S ABOUT
INNOVATION.
BECAUSE EVERYWHERE I GO EVERY
FOUR I GO IN.
I SEE THE INNOVATIONS THAT OUR
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HAS COME
UP WITH.
WHETHER IT'S RECYCLING WATER.
GOING THROUGH NEW WAYS OF
PROCESSING THINGS [inaudible]
IT.
WE ARE AT THE KEY IN THE LEADING
EDGE OF EVERYTHING.
AN AGRICULTURAL IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S REALLY AMAZING THAT WE
GET TO SEE THIS HERE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST AG
STATE.
IN THE NATION WE WE ARE THE
BREAD BASKET OF THE WORLD.
BUT IF YOU REALLY STOP AND YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
AG IS EVERYTHING.
IT'S THE SHOES YOUR WERE IN THE
SOCKS ON YOUR FEET.
YOUR SUIT YOUR CLOTHES YOUR
DRESSES.
IT'S EVERYWHERE.
EVERY SINGLE THING WE HAVE COME
FROM AN AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT.
IN THAT'S WHY I JUST WANNA SAY
HASH TAG THINK OF FORMER.
MISTER DALLI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
UP THINK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD --
AS YOU KNOW IN THE DELI FAMILY
EVERY DAY IS ACT DAY AND PROUD
TO BE.
A FARMER THAT TO SERVE ON THIS
FLOOR I'M I JUST WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU THAT CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES.
ALL KINDS OF COMMODITIES BUT I
WANT TO SHARE THE THAT THE MAIN
THING IS THAT THEY'RE THE SAFEST
COMMODITIES IN THE WORLD WE HAVE.
MORE.
REGULATIONS PUT ON CALIFORNIA
FARMERS AND WE STILL PROVIDE.
A GOOD SAFE PRODUCT NOT ONLY FOR
CALIFORNIANS BUT FOR THE WORLD
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO COME OUT
NEXT WEDNESDAY.
AND SEE ALL THE TECHNOLOGY AND
ALL THE KIDS ARE OUT THERE.
SHARING WHAT --
AGAS ABOUT IN CAL AND I JUST
WANNA SAY ONE LAST THING CLOSING.
EVERY TIME YOU TAKE A BITE OF
FOOD THINK THINK OF A FARMER
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
PUT IT TO YOUR TABLE.
I IN STE I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI.
IS COOLEY YOUR RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M DELIGHTED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
I TRAVELED OVER THE WEEKEND
SPENT TIME WITH LAWMAKERS FROM.
OTHER OF THE FIFTY STATES.
AND IT WAS INTERESTING TO FIND
AT DINNER.
THE CONVERSATION TURNED TO HOW.
ON THE EAST COAST.
WHEN THEY WINNER GROCERY STORES
AND WINNER?
THEY MARVELED AT THE ABUNDANCE
OF PRODUCE OF ALLCAME FROM
CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IDEA THAT WE ARE THE
BREAD BASKET TO THE NATION.
THE BREAD BASKET OF THE GLOBE.
YOU KNOW PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
GLOBAL BRAND IS IS NOT JUST OUR
PRODUCE. TO PROTECT US OF OUR
FIELDS.
BUT IT'S THE HELPFUL QUALITY OF
AND I THINK CALIFORNIA ENJOYS A
REP.
REPUTATION.
THAT THE FOOD GROWN HERE IS
GROWN WITH SAFE WHOLESOME
PRACTICES.
THAT THE AMOUNT OF RESIDUES ON
THE FOOD THIS SORT OF THING ARE
NOT TO BE WORRIED ABOUT
[inaudible]
SO.
WE WE HAVE THIS EXCEPTIONAL
QUALITY IN THE STATE WE ARE
INDEED THE BREAD BASKET OF THE
NATION.
AND NATURALLY THIS BECAUSE WE TO
OBSERVE THE ON THE UPPER WALL OF
THE ROTUNDA [inaudible]
THERE ARE. THIRTY SIX THIRTY
EIGHT DIFFERENT HORNS OF PLENTY
THAT TUMBLE DOWN.
BANNERS TO PRODUCE THE RING THE
UPPER WALL OF THE ROTUNDA.
OUR AGRICULTURAL PRODUCE WAS
LEFT IN THE EIGHTEEN FIFTY DOORS --
BELOW MISTER AROUND OVER THERE
ON THE SECOND FLOOR IF YOU LOOK
UP CAPITOL MALL.
WE HAVE ALWAYS SEEN OURSELVES AS
THIS PRODUCTIVE SPOT.
AND LIVING IN CALIFORNIA SEASON
TAKE FOR GRANTED BUT IN FACT IT
IS SOMETHING IS.
BECOMES A TOPIC OF CONVERSATION
WHEN YOU TRAVEL AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND WINNER.
IN A DEED IN THE GLOW.
SO IT'S A GREAT THING TO
CELEBRATE ON THIS AND I THINK
THE MEMBER FROM STOCKTON.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY WHICH
PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE THE
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF I RISE
[inaudible] TO SUPPORT.
BOB THIS RESOLUTION BUT I ALSO
RISE WITH A WORD OF CAUTION.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE TODAY IS
UNDER SUBSTANTIAL AND
SIGNIFICANT STRESS.
THEN I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE AND REMEMBER.
THAT MUCH OF WHAT THIS
LEGISLATURE PRODUCES IN THE WAY
OF REGULATION.
AT IN TAXES AND IN WATER POLICY.
HAS SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ASK THAT THE NEXT TIME
WE LOOK AT OF A BILL OR A
CONSTRICTION OF OF WATER TO
AGRICULTURE THE NEXT TIME WE ARE
WARNED BY AGRICULTURE THAT THERE
ARE SUBSTANTIAL.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
HAPPENING TO SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPENED HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
OUT OF THIS --
OUT OF THIS BUILDING.
I REPRESENT THEIR FRESNO
CALIFORNIA WAS THE MAYOR THERE
FOR EIGHT YEARS AND NOW
REPRESENT THEM UP HERE.
FRESNO IS THE FIFTH LARGEST CITY
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
THE CITY THAT AGRICULTURE HAS
BUILT.
REPEATEDLY I GO BACK TO MY
HOMETOWN AND TALK TO PEOPLE IN
AGRICULTURE I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WE ARE FACING IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA.
THE POSSIBILITY OF A HALF A
MILLION ACRES OF PRIME
AGRICULTURE FOLLOWED BECAUSE OF
THE INSECURITY OF WATER.
THERE ARE OTHER CONSIDERATIONS
IN MANY OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCERS THINK ABOUT ACTUALLY%
LEAVING THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE SEVERAL FRIENDS WHO
RECENTLY HAVE GIVEN UP ON
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE TAKEN THEIR
AGRICULTURE TO OTHER PLACES
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
SOME OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
HIGH COST OF ELECTRICITY SOME OF
IT HAS TO DO WITH THE HIGH COST
OF ENERGY.
SOME OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE IN
SECURITY OF THOUGHT WATER.
AND SO ALTHOUGH THIS IS A TIME
TO CELEBRATE WITH JOY THE
BOUNTIES OF AGRICULTURE.
MEMBERS PLEASE.
KEEP IN THE BACK OF YOUR MIND.
THAT AGRICULTURE PRESENTLY IS
UNDER SIGNIFICANT STRESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND LET'S NOT MISS.
THE NEWS THAT WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO IN ORDER TO MAYBE
TURN THE TIDE.
ON THAT IN SECURITY AND PAY OF A
SOME SPECIFIC ATTENTION. TO THE
WAY IN THE MANNER IN WHICH WE
CAN.
HONESTLY AND EFFECTIVELY BUT YET
WITH A SINCERE SUPPORT FOR
AGRICULTURE.
LEGISLATE IN THIS.
CURRENT CONDITION.
AND SO I RISE TO SUPPORT BUT
ALSO WITH A CAUTIONARY WARNING
THAT THINGS ARE NOT ALL AS ROSY
AS THEY SEEM AN AGRICULTURE.
AND WE NEED TO LISTEN TO
AGRICULTURE WHEN THEY SAY THIS
KEEPS US AWAKE AT NIGHT.
AND WE ARE CHALLENGED BY THESE
REAL POSSIBILITIES SO LET'S
CELEBRATE TODAY.
BUT LET'S BE CAREFUL TOMORROW
THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
DOCTOR EGGMAN IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OF THE
ROLE.
EVER SINCE IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
HR TWENTY THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE.
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
CITY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND EXACT
COUNT OR ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWENTY EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
ESTATES AND TRUSTS.
A CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS IS CONSENT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE RLE AND HOW THEY THE VOTE
I SEVENTY SIX NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE QUORUM CALL IS NOT LIFTED.
THE CORE CALLS NOT LIFTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
SO YOU MAY GIVE RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE AND TURNING.
IN THE MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES ON A I AM.
HONORED TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF WILLIAM MCLAUGHLIN
JUNIOR.
A CONSTITUENT OF MINE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO HONOR PROMINENT REAL
ESTATE DEVELOPER.
AND WHEN I REFLECT UPON HIS LIFE
YOU KNOW.
IT IS BEEN SET OF INSTITUTIONS
INSTITUTIONS THE LINCOLN SHADOW
OF ONE PERSON.
AND THERE IS THIS QUALITY IN A
LIFE WELL LIVED IT YOU GET
INVOLVED IN THINGS.
AND THINGS FLOW FROM THAT.
ANOTHER EXPRESSION WHEN I THINK
OF MISTER MCLAUGHLIN IS THE
RELEASE OF ENERGY.
HOW BORN IN CALIFORNIA HE WENT
ON TO CREATE JOBS FOR MANY OTHER
PEOPLE?
BECAUSE OF HIS CHOSEN PROFESSION.
AND SO THIS QUALITY OF BEING THE
SORT OF PERSON THAT.
RATE SOMETHING GREATER THAN
THEMSELVES ANDERS PASSED THEM.
DID INDEED IN THEIR LIFE FOR
LEASES ENERGY.
IN A COMMUNITY IS AN OUTSTANDING
QUALITIES CELEBRATE TODAY.
OUR MISTER MCLAUGHLIN PASSED
AWAY FEBRUARY TWENTY FIFTH AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY SEVEN HE WAS
BORN IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
JANUARY FOURTEENTH. NINETEEN
THIRTY TWO SO HE SPENT HIS EARLY
YEARS IN PIEDMONT.
BEFORE MOVING TO SANDERS A IN.
NINETEEN FORTY THREE HE WAS A
NINETEEN FORTY NINE GRADUATE OF
SAN IS A HIGH SCHOOL.
GOING ON TO UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY WHERE HE
EARNED A B. S. IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION.
WHILE AT UC BERKELEY HE ENROLLED
IN THE ROTC.
SO THE DURING THE KOREAN WAR
UPON HIS GRADUATION.
HE INTERVIEW A AND SERVICE AND
THEN SENT ON A SEAPLANE TENDER.
ARM FOR TWO YEARS DURING THE
KOREAN WAR BEFORE COMING HOME.
TAKING THAT BUSINESS AGREE.
UPON HIS RETURN HOME HE WAS WENT
TO WORK FOR COLDWELL BANKER IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
DISTINGUISHING HIMSELF SO HE WAS
EVENTUALLY TRANSFERRED UP HERE
TO SACRAMENTO.
AND HE BECAME THE SALES MANAGER
AND THE COMMERCIAL MANAGER.
AND THEN BY NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
HE LAUNCHED OUT ON HIS OWN.
SO WE TOOK WHAT HE HAD LEARNED
AND DECIDED HE CAN DO MORE WITH
THAT.
HE STARTED HIS OWN FIRM
MCLAUGHLIN AND COMPANY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
IN THAT ROLE HE DEVELOPED A VERY
ACTIVE COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE
BROKERAGE.
AND PROPERTY MANAGEMENT FIRM.
AND SPENT THE REST OF HIS CAREER
DEVELOPING INDUSTRIAL PARKS AND
SHOPPING CENTERS THROUGHOUT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS IS WHERE I FEEL HE
BECAME A JOB CREATORS.
TAKE IN RAW LAND FACILITIES
DEVELOPMENT TO SUPPORT JOB
CREATION AND RETAIL AREAS.
HE LOVES WORLD TRAVEL ENSURING
CULTURES FROM THE AGE OF SIXTEEN
HE HAD A LOVE OF SCUBA DIVING.
WHICH MAY TELL US SOMETHING
ABOUT THE ALLURE OF U. S. NAVY
TO HIM.
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE TRAVEL
ABOUT THE GLOBES SEE WHAT SIZE
TUITION AND OFFER.
EVEN FILL MEAN WHAT HE SAW --
MISTER MCLAUGHLIN WAS A
DEDICATED FATHER AND HUSBAND.
WHO ALWAYS STRIVE FOR THE BEST
FOR HIS FAMILY?
AND IS REMEMBERED AS A PASSION
GRACES CARING AND GIVING.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
CLAIRE.
LEHRER WHO HAD FOUR SONS DAVIS
STEVE JEFF AND CAL WAS SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND BILLS ONLY.
OF FOUR CHILDREN VIRGINIA TOM GM
BILLY WITH ELEVEN GRANDCHILDREN.
IT IS NOT A REMEMBER HIM ON THIS
DAY AND I ASKED WE CHURN IN
MEMORY OF WILLIAM MCLAUGHLIN
JUNIOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY
[inaudible]
MR GRAY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE OF SERIES.
CALIFORNIAN ALL THE TWENTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. TO EXTEND OUR
CONDOLENCES.
THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF
CHARLES ARABIAN.
CHARLES PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE
OF NINETY FIVE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH.
CHARLES WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE TO PARENTS WHO ARE
MEANING IMMIGRANTS.
HE WAS THE ELDEST OF FOUR
CHILDREN HE GRADUATED FROM
SAYING HIGH SCHOOL IN.
NINETEEN FORTY ONE ONLY MONTHS
BEFORE THE UNITED STATES ENTERED
WORLD WAR.
TWO IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO
CHARLES A LISTED WITH THE U. S.
ARMY AIR CORPS.
AS AN AIRPLANE MECHANIC GUNNER
AND FLIGHT ENGINEER.
IN NINETEEN FORTY FIVE CHARLES
WAS A CREW MEMBER OF THE GENERAL
JAMES DOOLITTLE'S FAMOUS FLYING
FORTRESS THAT PARTICIPATED THE
WORST FINAL EUROPEAN BOMBARDMENT.
RETURN TO CIVILIAN LIFE IN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX CHARLES BEGAN
WORKING AS A MADE A CHANGE IN
HERE WITH PACIFIC BELL.
RETIRING SOME THIRTY YEARS LATER.
TODAY MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY WE
ARE JOINED BY CHARLES WHETHER.
MRS DONNA SARABIA.
HIS TWO DAUGHTERS DEBRA IN TERRY.
ALONG WITH EXTENDED FAMILY AND
FRIENDS.
PLEASE JOIN ME MEMBERS IN BOTH
HONORING A LIFE WELL LIVED.
IN A JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF
CHARLES CHARADE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY.
MISTER DOWLING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ASKED THAT WE DURING THE
MEMORY.
OF MELVIN AND BEEN A REBEL.
NOBODY'S BEEN A REBEL WERE
BROTHERS FROM READING AREA WHO
TRAGICALLY LOST THEIR LIVES
ALONG WITH A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE BROTHERS IN A PLANE CRASH
IN ETHIOPIA.
THEY WERE KNOWN FOR THEIR STRONG
FAMILY TIES.
AND LOVE OF ADVENTURE.
THESE BROTHERS SHARE A STRONG
BOND ALWAYS PUSHING THEMSELVES
TO BE BETTER AND TO DO BETTER.
THEY WERE KNOWN BY THEIR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS. FOR THEIR LOYALTY
INTEGRITY AND RISING RAISING UP
PEOPLE AROUND THEM WITH THEIR
LOVE AND COMPASSION.
MELVIN IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
BRITTNEY.
WHO IS EXPECTING THEIR FIRST
CHILD?
WE WILL KEEP BRITNEY AND ALL THE
REFER REBEL BROTHERS FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS IN OUR PRAYERS.
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY.
OF MELVIN AND BENNETT REBEL.
THANK YOU MISTER DOWLING.
MR FARM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMANY MEMORY.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MY CONSTITUENT HAROLD EUGENE
MUSIC.
PASSED AWAY ON SUNDAY FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH WEEKS BEFORE HIS
EIGHTY SIX PER DAY.
HE WAS A PILLAR OF BAKERSFIELD
WILL BE MISSED BY MANY.
HAROLD WAS BORN BY TALK TO
ARTHUR AND PRO MUSIC IN
CHILDRESS TEXAS IT WAS A CHILD
OF THE DUST BOWL.
BEFORE EVENTUALLY MADE HIS WAY
TO CALIFORNIA WHERE HE WOULD
SPEND THE REST OF HIS LIFE AS A
BUSINESSMAN.
AND DEVOTED HUSBAND TO A
SWEETHEART LORRAINE IN A
MARRIAGE THAT LASTED FOR SIXTY
EIGHT WONDERFUL YEARS.
HE WAS A PERSISTENT FISHERMEN
AND AN EVEN BETTER STORY TELLER
WITH A JOKE FOR ANY SITUATION
BUT HERA WAS SERIOUS AS HE LET
EVERYONE KNOW DELORAINE WITH THE
CATCH OF HIS LIFE.
THEY HAD FOUR CHILDREN EIGHTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND THIRTY NINE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND COUNTING.
HE WAS ALSO UNCLE HAROLD TO
NUMEROUS NIECES AND NEPHEWS AND
BOSS TO ANYONE WHO WANTED A JOB
UNTIL HE RETIRED FROM MUSIC'S
TRANSMISSION AND PRECISION
TRANSMISSION PARTS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE HE LEFT A
LEGACY OF HARD WORK LOVE FOR THE
LORD AND FAMILY SOLIDARITY.
AS THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MUCH FONG MEMBERS
PLEASE READ THE NAMES OF THE
DEATHS TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
OUR QUEST RETURNING MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL.
MEMBER MEMBERS A COUPLE OF BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENTS I UNDERSTAND THAT
TODAY IS MR KEN COOLEY IS
BIRTHDAY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH NINETEENTH
TRACK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTIETH CHECK
IN SESSION AND THURSDAY MARCH
TWENTY FIRST.
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN.
ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I AM READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER BONTA
MOVES AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY
FIRST.
AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED